I am very mindful of
what was presented as to Mr
folders mental health history I'm also
mindful of Devastation calls to the
victims and their families
so I think this sentence balances both
principal term
in this sense will be count three the
245 A2 on Mr Latham
course selects the midterm three years
of State Prison
for the gun there will be an additional
four years in state prison consecutive
and then for the ray Molly Andrew
allegation that was found true it will
be three years consecutive to that so
for count three it will be a total of 10
years in state prison as to count one
the murder in the first degree of Mr
askedon
the sentence will be the term prescribed
by law which is 25 years of life
conditions there will be the 1202 2.53 V
allegation
which is consecutive that will be an
additional 25 years to life so for count
one alone it would be 50 years to life
the total centers would be 60 60 years
to life in the present the court would
also recommend
to the Department of Corrections that
the dependently housed in a facility
that would address his mental health
needs